this episode is brought to you by never
surrender a Galaxy Quest documentary
learn more at fandom not link / never
surrender
[Music]
once upon a time
Disney spent years working on a classic
2d animated Rapunzel movie but when
Princess and the Frog blocked and Shrek
soared a box-office heights King Eisner
decreed they'd start over with a joke
filled cgi ROM for girls and boys alike
and you know what it's better than
frozen come at me haters tangled in joy
another fairy tale where they eat the
parents before our story even begins and
meet Rapunzel a beautiful hostage with
70 feet of magic hair not only can it
grant eternal life it doesn't even get
nasty after dragging you through the
forest follow along with this weird
overeager homeschooled kid who really
wants to see the kingdoms annual fire
hazard for a birthday I want to see the
floating lights but everything will
change when she tries to kill I had some
intruder and hide his clips in a closet
she'll fall for Flynn Rider hi a playboy
with a mean case of DreamWorks fakes and
plans just one of the narcissists taking
advantage of the magic shut-in as
rapunzel is under the spell of a witch
Mother Gothel wait is she a witch or as
Disney just conditioned me to think
every childless owner woman is evil
anyhoo she'll use the powers of guilt
shame and gaslighting to stop her barely
legal daughter from running off with a
26-year old career criminal and gets
murdered by a chameleon for her troubles
and that's we're not letting her marry
literally the first guy she's ever met
which everyone watch a man by the horse
now a lot squeal with glee and a B story
ripped straight from a tech savory
cartoon as Maximus the horse cops dogs
playing like The Terminator and
continues the grand animation tradition
of turning every animal sidekick no
matter what species into a dog
sing-along to a film that sort of gives
up on being a musical halfway through
featuring half an albums worth of Alan
Menken b-sides that still manages to hit
the 4 main genres of Disney song
joyfully going about your daily routine
play guitar
[Music]
I'm an obvious villain pretending to be
your best friend mother knows best I'm a
tough guy revealing my soft side cuz the
way dog deep inside
we I'm in love I'm the last I see
[Music]
okay before you get mad we didn't make
parodies for these you have to know the
originals for to work go ahead
hum attune to healing incantation oh
wait
so embark on a new Disney classic that's
charming funny and romantic throughout
except for the nonsensical ending where
your tears can suddenly heal the sick
that is unless you're familiar with the
source material where Rapunzel's tears
cure blindness since her prints couches
own eyes out after throwing himself off
the tower in despair now that's a grim
fairy tale starry golden girl Harry
Potter Joey Tribbiani how you doing
cartoon cartoon cartoon cartoon cartoon
chameleon nobs in Shaw and an amis
Maximus ho Sidious steed - a kidnap
princess 7 - the true king and I will
have my vengeance in this life or the
next
Disney's Tower of Terror so a young
blond girl with a wreath in her hair and
takes a birthday trip with her shady
boyfriend to witness an annual ritual
hmm anyone else getting strong midsummer
vibes here thanks for watching
by grabthar's hammer click the box on
the left to learn more about never
surrender I used to think that my life
was a tragedy but now I realize it's a
comedy pepper er Plus Tony equals
pepperoni please say something